it's great to virtually visit Stanford
uh as mentioned I actually was a post uh
at Stanford uh working with Jeff here on
data visualization so it's great to
actually connect back um so today I will
be sharing some of my past and also
ongoing research work designing and
building dat data visualization systems
and tools so my research group is called
human data interaction group uh we are
primarily interested in designing and
developing human centered techniques and
systems to support interactive data
analysis and also datadriven
communication so uh these are my
wonderful uh PhD students and uh we're
working together trying to actually uh
think about how we can actually best uh
enable users and uh machines to work
together so when a user wants to gain
some insights about a data set or trying
to communicate some findings about a
data set they do that through an
interactive system and um oftentimes
user needs to convey their goals and
their intents and preferences to the
system and which is processed by the
system and in response the system will
tries to produce generate some visual
representations of data which needs to
be interpreted and consumed by the user
so basically in this kind of a loop we
have um um basically this interaction
between human and machine and L ligher
uh in back in 1960 actually proposed his
vision on human computer symbiosis which
basically is about a very tight coupling
between the human and also the machine
um he anticipated that uh in this
collaboration model uh humans will will
be the uh ones who are setting the goals
formulating the hypothesis determining
the criteria and then performing the
evaluations and the Machine on the other
hand will do the more kind of a mundane
and potentially repetitive work um and
then together if this symbiotic
relationship actually works well uh the
human and the Machine can actually
produce more effective results than
either the man or the machine alone can
actually
produce so in the real world of however
in order to enable this kind of a
symbiotic relationship we actually face
two kinds of challenges uh on one hand
oftentimes uh the visual representations
produced by the systems can be
potentially in effective or can be very
hard to interpret um by the humans and
on the other hand uh uh humans Al
sometimes have troubles or difficulties
articulating their goals intents and
preferences because because there is a
misalignment between users mental models
and the systems models so in my talk
today I will talk about two threads of
research work trying to address these
two challenges uh the first thread is
really trying to understand how we can
produce or generate effective and
interpretable visual representations of
data and we will be looking at this
problem in the context of visual
analysis and summarization of event
sequence data and in the second part of
my talk I will be talking about how we
can potentially align System model and
human mental models uh in the context of
authoring and reusing data visualization
designs so let me start with the first
thread first um so um in our daily life
and work actually we encounter lots of
event sequence data so when I was
working at Adobe um the company as
analysts were actually interested in
understanding how customers come to
adobe's uh website and then navigate on
the website so every click uh the user
makes on the website generates a Tim
stamp and a page name so this basically
is are the different attributes of of an
event right so as the user navigates to
different parts of the website all their
interactions generates a sequence of
events so this is one uh example of
event sequence data um in um commercial
domains and these are called click
streams uh event sequence data are also
pervasive in many other domains so for
example uh when a patient comes to a
hospital hospital uh they often have to
go through some kind of a checkups um so
this is this is a data set from a pediat
pediatric trauma unit where the patients
needs to go through the so-called ABCDE
evance checking so Airway breathing
circulation Etc so the uh um the doctors
actually are interested in trying to
understand the potential hidden patterns
inside these records for example is this
is the procedure actually strictly F
followed um are actually there are any
kind of deviations from the expected
procedures so in general we have
clickstream data patient records uh as
event sequence data but also we have
other kinds of uh data sets like human
movements uh development workflows
application log data and also digital
marketing in touch points and the tasks
that try that you that the analyst tries
to actually um perform on these data
sets can also vary quite a bit sometimes
people are interested in trying to
identify the common patterns in the data
set so for example what are the typical
navigation paths on the website in other
cases it's more about detecting
anomalies so for example in the example
of U uh a patient records uh the doctors
want to know do patients actually go
through essential checks in the right
order and in other cases people are are
more interested in doing some clustering
trying to group similar events and
sequences to identify uh groups of
behavior and of course uh oftentimes in
order to answer these questions we need
to uh visualize the data and then
explore the data and there are
visualizations available for us to
actually apply to these kind of data
sets so here we're looking at two
examples the sanki diagram on top and
the icle plot at the bottom uh so
commercial tools like uh Google
analytics or adobe analytics actually
make use of these visualizations to show
uh um event sequence data set um the
problem is that um these visualizations
are not very scalable so here we're
applying the seni diagram to only a
moderately sized data set of a
clickstreams consisting of only a dozen
unique events and only six steps and the
seni diagram becomes really hard to
understand similarly if we're only
looking at only 200 different sequences
of patients records um the icle plot at
the bottom is really
unintelligible um so the problem is then
how do we produce effective and
interpretable visual representations of
data uh in this case uh event sequence
data so in order to do that we need to
perform potentially data summarization
or data reduction so that we can
actually reduce the number of visual
items to be shown to the users uh so we
first into the data mining literature
and we found a technique called
sequential data pattern mining so here's
an example we have five input sequences
um and they're going from top to bottom
and what sequential pattern mining does
is that it is tries to identify a common
set of events across multiple sequences
where the order of these events in the
original sequences are preserved so here
for example we're looking at a pattern
E1 E2 E3 E4 E9 and they appear in all of
the five input sequences and similarly
we can find other kinds of patterns
which may only happen in a subset of
this data so here we have a shorter
pattern and we can continue to find more
if we lower the kind of the percentage
of the uh sequence required um So based
on this uh Technique we can actually
design some uh visualizations trying to
help people to make sense of their data
so here is a representation of a pattern
mined from the data set this shows
people are actually going through the uh
consumer admin landing page and then
they're going to pay their bill later we
also show the amount of people going
through each of these Milestone events
in the pattern and then we show the uh
individual sequences matching this
pattern uh as an i icle plot and we can
highlight the Milestone or key events uh
in the icle plot as shown here and we
can also add some additional information
to show the frequency frequency of these
individual uh sequences and with this
basic setup we can enable people to
interactively explore the data so for
example when I click on the event I can
interactively align these different
sequences by that event so that I can
more clearly see what is happening
before an event or in between a pair of
events so that's kind of like the first
iteration of the visualizations we came
up with and what we were doing basically
is trying to follow bench item and
information seeking Mantra right
overview first zoom and futter and then
detail on demand so here we're using
this particular visualization as the
overview the question is is this an
effective overview so when we show this
to the um um the users they their first
impression was that okay there are
actually 10 different um uh SE sequences
or patterns uh which are shown to me
which means that there are actually 10
different groups of behaviors but this
is a very wrong interpretation of the
visualization if we look at for example
these three highlighted patterns here we
actually see that uh these three
patterns are actually telling uh us
about the same thing uh it's about the
users consumers check out loading page
right so we have very similar events
like check out loaded check out uh load
loading and then confirming order and
then submitting order and Etc so
actually there are lots of overlapping
sequences between these three patterns
so this is actually potentially
misleading um so in order to address
this problem U we actually were inspired
by this idea uh called a branching
pattern so this is a visualization
appeared in the visualization arts
program at this 2016 where people are
trying to visualize how the different
rowes actually converge to Rome uh so if
we were actually very inspired by this
visualization because we thought well if
every users or every customers's Journey
on a website can be actually thought of
as kind of like a physical Journey then
their navigation path may actually
differ quite a bit but there are some
commonalities in terms of the Milestone
events they come through right so um can
we actually design a data mining
algorithm that tries to actually pull
out these branching patterns from the
data set and uh based on this idea we
came up with a corlow and this is
actually uh the visualization produced
by corlow uh the it's basically uh
showing the same data set uh we starting
with around 5,000 different uh visits uh
we see that about
55.2% of these uh customers they go to
the checkout loading page and the Y AIS
includes the average number of steps uh
going to that page so it took people
about every on average like 12 steps to
go to the checkout loading page and we
see about 25 around 25% of the customers
they go to the adobe's plan page to
manage their plans and then for people
who went to the checkout loading page we
can see the stepbystep uh per process of
how they actually go through the uh
order process right and and then we also
see the gray areas these are the places
where people are leaving or dropping out
um so we can also see more coherent uh
things behaviors going on in other parts
of the website so this visualization
basically gives us a more complete
understanding of what's going down in
people's navigation beh Behavior without
actually any overlapping uh
patterns under the hood corlow uses a u
uh three-step algorithm a recursive
algorithm to produce this kind of
visualizations so we first try to rank
the events divide the sequences and then
trim the sequences and we do this
recursively until we reach the end of
all the sequences so here's a very brief
illustration so for example here we have
six input sequences and we first try to
rank uh all the events in these
sequences by some predefined Matrix so
for example here C is ranked top because
it appears in the most number of
sequences with the lowest average index
uh in in these sequences so we add C to
the print branching pattern and then we
divide the sequences into two groups
those containing C and those not
containing C and then we trim uh the
sequence is containing C so that we can
basically focus on the subsequences
after uh the first uh event C uh so
that's the first iteration and then we
basically do this recursively for all
the groups that have been generated um
because of this process uh doing rank
divide and trim again and and basically
that's how this um uh branching pattern
is being actually mined so looking at
these two different visual
representations of the same data set I
think most of us will agree that uh the
core flow representation the one on the
right is actually more effective than
the one on the left right so reflecting
on this uh uh process actually uh we
realized that in order to produce
interpretable visualization and data
reduction often it makes sense to start
with visualization design instead with
uh instead of starting with the data
mining algorithm so that's actually the
first lesson we learned from this uh
exercise and over the years uh actually
uh we see more and more visualization
summarization techniques uh that came
out trying to uh visualize event
sequence data in many different domains
and these techniques are getting more
and more sophisticated uh so for example
here is a new approach trying to propose
an information the theoretic uh way to
summarize event sequence data so given
the input sequences uh we try to First
cluster them into distinct clusters and
then we try to uh summar each cluster
using a sequential pattern um so in this
case here the main problem is trying to
decide how do we actually how many
clusters do we need and in order to
solve this problem we can use an
information theoretic approach where the
description length of the data set can
be defined as consisting of the overview
which are the sequential patterns and
then the encoding of the raw data based
on the overview which are the
corrections of the patterns which can
lead us to the original input data and
then based this formulation uh the
problem becomes basically trying to
achieve a balance or trade-off between
the Simplicity of the overview and its
information loss right so we can
actually mathematically formulate the
description length of any potential uh
visual summarization generated using
this approach and then we can try to
come up with optimization algorithms
trying to generate the right number of
clusters so that's one approach and
another one is basically trying to
leverage deep learning models like
sequence to sequence models right so
this is uh more recent paper where the
authors tries to use an encoder and
decoder structure trying to basically uh
summarize the probabilities of events
happening in each time SCS in a sequence
and then we can basically visualize uh
this uh this learned representations
from the data to the
users uh so given all these different
approaches actually we see many many
potential algorithms and tools that are
available for people to visual their
event sequence data uh unfortunately uh
all these um tools produce very
different results uh so here we're
looking at three visualizations visual
summarizations of the same data set
produced by different tools and they
differ in terms of the structure of the
summary some are in the form of
sequences some are in the form of trees
and some are in the form of directive as
graphs and then we Al these summaries
also differred widely in terms of
content right like what kind of events
are included what are the relationships
between the events and also the exact
quantitative information and the
granularity of these summaries can also
vary quite a bit uh which are manifested
in terms of the number of clusters and
also the number of
branches so we actually did a survey on
the um around 15 uh also papers that
tries to propose different ways to
visually summarize this uh event
sequence data and we realized actually
most of the uh technique implementation
are not available there's no way for us
to actually try them uh and all these um
techniques are actually evaluated
through case studies there are no
standard evaluation benchmarks and
metrics and often times there's also a
lack of explanations for the performance
of a techniques uh if it if uh and if uh
summarization actually works we don't
know why it works that way and if it
fails to produce a meaningful
visualization we don't know why that
happens so in order to address this
problem uh Zena my student Zena and I we
uh conducted the first comparative
evaluation of V summarization techniques
for event sequence data so we we
collected six different data sets in
very different domains and we identified
uh a user task for each of these data
set and then for each data set we try to
actually analyze the data set and come
up with some ground truth which are
basically the main insights we
discovered from the data set uh and then
we conducted a crowdsourcing study
trying to let people decide how accurate
or how how in interpretable these visual
summaries are so users are basically
presented with uh an Insight which is
the fact and then they're shown a visual
summary uh visual summary one at a time
so they need to give a lier scale rating
on how well the visualization actually
represents the given fact or the ground
truth they also need to enter a short
explanation for their rating So based on
this study we found that actually there
is a trade-off between the summary
quality and also the time taken for
people to interpret the visual summaries
so here we have three lines each line is
a a task and then we we're evaluating
three different techniques and you can
basically see there is a kind of like a
inverse uh kind of like there is
actually correlation between uh the
average lier scale rating and the amount
of time U taken to to actually uh read
those interpret those summaries we also
find that the summary quality rating
depends on two factors content and
interpretability so content basically is
about the match between the
visualization pattern and insights in
other words whether important events and
Associated quantitative of information
are actually included in the
visualization and in terms of
interpretability is really about the
effort needed to extract the information
from the visualization by the users
uh so how easy it is to actually read
and also understand the visualization
and this is only the first study and we
doing actually more additional follow-up
work um but this basically led us to
this um new area of work where we need
where we realize we need to perform
human- centered comparison to evaluate
these techniques and in order to do so
we really need to do lots of research on
the evaluation methodology the metrics
we use and also potentially developing
benchmarks uh in terms of both data set
and also metrics uh for this kind of
research right so that's kind of the
first thread of um uh my work uh trying
to produce visual representations of
event sequence data uh and we did
different Works in terms of
visualization designs designing new data
mining algorithms and also coming up
with evaluation strategies trying to
compare different
techniques so next I will U talk about
the second threet of my work focusing on
the articulation problem how do we
enable people to articulate their intent
effectively to the system and we will be
talking about this in the context of uh
visualization creation all right so
there are actually many different tools
and very powerful tools out there
enabling people to create an expressive
visualization and so you are probably
familiar with D3 or vegalite or Tableau
M GT plus too right um but still there
are potential limitations um um um
for for for each of these tools so let's
take a few uh example let's take a look
at a few examples so here we're looking
at a stacked bar chart uh this chart
basically shows how often do politicians
tell truth or lies right so um the color
indicates different categories like
ranging from uh uh false to True uh and
different degrees of uh amount of lies
and then each roow basically is a
politician and uh the width of these
rectangles represent uh the frequency um
of uh basically uh falling into each
category and this is a perfectly fine
chart but often times people would like
to see how the the truth and the the
lies actually diverge so people often
actually adopted slightly variation of
this Design This is called a diverging
stack bar chart so basically we try to
align uh these bars in the center so
that it's more clear to see who lies
more and who actually tell truths more
um so in order to go from the design to
the left to the design on the right
actually most people's intuition would
be just trying to align these different
bars in the center by the gray area
right so that's a very int intuitive way
to describe how you would actually uh
create some the design on the right but
this is not how many of the
visualization toolkits uh work um so so
these two case often so for example this
is the code you need to write to
actually create a diverging St bar chart
in GG plot 2 in order to do this you
have to actually go back to the source
data and then change all the data
related to the false category to
negative values and then basically you
need to regenerate the visualization
again which is counterintuitive to many
people's mental models so here's another
a very simple chart this is uh a mosaic
chart or sometimes people call it a
meral chart
uh so here we're looking at basically
different
manufacturers uh of computer devices and
then different categories of computer
devices phone laptop desktop and then
the um basically the proportion of uh
each device um by different manufacturer
right so it's a very in uh
straightforward
visualization uh when we actually ask
people how they would describe or create
this kind of visualization I think many
of the people thought describing this
visualization as some kind of like a
slicing and dicing a rectangle so you
start with a rectangle and then you
slice and dice it in horizontally and
vertically by manufacturer and then by
uh the U the device type might be an
easy way to create this visualization
however this is not for example how
Tableau Works uh so my Zena when he
worked on the uh uh event sequence
evaluation paper she needed to create
some something like this and she
couldn't figure out how to do that in
tableau she has to search online and
found this kind of 16-step tutorial on
how to create a mosaic chart in Tableau
which is really tedious um so in general
I think there is a misalignment between
people's mental model and visualization
models and oftentimes it's really hard
for people to articulate what they want
to a system and so here and BOS talk and
here actually argued that uh many of
these powerful visualization systems can
be intimidating to novices or they can
also be
inflexible uh so the abstractions used
may be actually foreign to the users so
as a result designers may actually often
resort to vector-based drawing programs
to realize that their intent so how do
designers actually work in Vector um
based drawing tools so here's an example
um often these tools are offer direct
manipulation and offer a what you see is
what you get interface right so if you
move a shape around
um these Dynamic guides appear trying to
let you know if objects are aligned or
how far they are from each other um we
also see tools like figma so here is a
feature in figma which allows you to
basically try to um perform responsive
design so once you set up some
constraints um and then you can
basically dynamically resize an object
and all the other object will actually
uh respond accordingly um so can we
achieve something like this for data
visualization creation can people create
data visualization uh using a similar
interaction Paradigm uh so this has been
a problem that people people have been
exploring for a while uh so when I was
at Stanford actually I attended a talk
by Brad Victor where he first proposed
this idea of drawing Dynamic
visualizations and this is one of his
demos right you can basically draw uh
These Bars and populate them with data
and then you can directly manipulate the
for example the um text labels U map uh
data to the content of these labels uh
changing the colors um and you can also
potentially dynamically change the
scales of these um um bars um so it's a
very intuitive and also very uh um
direct um manipulation experience um
when I was working at Adobe we also
worked on something similar it's called
project Lincoln again we were trying to
enable users to directly draw things in
the canvas and manipulate it directly um
and also binding different visual
properties of these shapes to data so
when we actually presented Lincoln at a
conference um people were actually quite
SK SK skeptical about it um so Nathan
Yao who runs the flowing data blog uh he
after he watched the linking he wrote a
blog post um and he basically says that
well with data visualization often times
you should start with data and then you
work on the geometry and colors and
Aesthetics later on so the data really
informs the design and he thinks project
Lincoln is trying to flip this workflow
and it doesn't seem to make much sense
to him um so he's basically saying my
brain was confused and my my gut there's
no um I can see why he was not very
convinced because uh the kind of the U
mainstream approach to create
visualization often times is is what we
know as grammar of Graphics right so um
in order to create a visualization you
start with data and then you go through
a number of different proc stages in a
process right you define the variables
the algebra the scales uh statistics
geometry and so on and in doing so
basically you are building up a formal
specification of what you want the
visualization to be like and then you
can pass this formal specification to a
renderer which will compile the
specification and produce the final
visualization for you so this this is a
very powerful idea and it has been
implemented in many programming
libraries and toolkits and it has been
demonstrated to be really expressive
able to support a wide range of
visualization designs it is unknown if
this the ideas of direct manipulation
can actually scale to many different
visualization
designs so we were basically interested
in understanding can we develop a
similar kind of visualization grammar
but based on the uh direct manipulation
Paradigm um so our research question
then basically is trying to uh come up
with a framework for manipulable
semantic components which are basically
graphical objects and also Associated
relationships that can be visually
represented and manipulated at design
time and we are interested in
understanding what are the semantic
components in data visualization design
and what are the operations to
manipulate these components with data so
in order to answer these questions we
can conducted a two-year formative study
with three different designers uh we
work with them um one hour per week and
we ask them to use their favorite tools
it could be Adobe Illustrator it could
be figma to create some visualizations
we give to them and based on their
workflows we came up with around 40
different storyboards and mo apps and we
distilled this into a set of components
and operations uh so I won't go into the
details of the uh specific of this
framework basically we have visual
objects which are Mark glue gliph uh
collection and reference object and we
have parametric layout uh things
basically trying to um uh position items
using some kind of automated layout like
grid layout stacking and so on we have
encodings and scales which are Central
to data visualization we also have
graphical constraints like alignment and
also a
fixation and then we have a set of
operations which can which we Define to
operate on these visual objects and
layouts um so we implemented this
framework uh in a library called mascot
uh standing for manipulable semantic
components uh and we're able to
demonstrate its expressive Power by
actually producing a gallery of diverse
visualization designs um so this work
basically lays the foundation for many
applications for doing interactive
visualization um so one application is
actually we can enable people to author
visualizations from scratch
uh using what you see is what you get
approach and so this is implemented in a
system called Data illustrator um as the
name suggests basically is trying to
adopt the Paradigm of interaction in
Adobe Illustrator but for data
visualizations so here is the interface
for data illustrator uh we have uh a two
bar on the top U so you can see we have
some the regular drawing tools and also
some of the operations in the mascot
framework and then we have the input
data at the bottom
and that's the CSV data you work with
and then in the center we have the
canvas so that is where you draw shapes
you manipulate shapes uh and and
basically do all the editing you want
and on the right we have a layers view
which basically shows the hierarchy of
the organizations of these visual
objects on the canvas and we also have a
property inspector panel panel which
shows all the different visual
properties for each of the visual
objects and you can actually perform
data binding in the this panel as well
so let's take a look at how data
illustrator Works in action uh so our
goal is trying to create a um very
simple um pie chart design like this so
we have two different countries and two
different years and we want to visualize
the house households expenditure pattern
uh in these countries in different years
so at the bottom right we have the input
data we have so we have four attributes
country year category and also
percentage um in order to create
something like this in the grammar of
Graphics basically what we need to do as
we saw earlier is trying to actually
write a form of specification and here's
how we can create something in similar
in data illustrator so we first try to
uh use the circle tool to draw a circle
and then we repeat it by the country
variable there are two different
countries in this data set UK and New
Zealand right and then we can keep
repeating this structure to by a
different variable ear so then we can
basically get this simple grid layout I
can do some customizations of the axis
to make the axis look nicer right and I
can dynamically change the gap between
these different uh visual objects uh on
the canvas and then after that we can
select any of these circles uh and then
we can divide it by the household
spending variable um so that gives us
basically all the pies we need each Pi
for each uh uh expenditure category and
then we combined the angle of the pi and
also the color of the pi to appropriate
data attributes and in a very few in
very few clicks we are already creating
uh uh something similar to the end
result we want and then now we can
further do some kind of a customization
so the default color palette doesn't
seem really nice so I can basically use
this interactive lend to pick the color
I
want
and finally I can do more touchups so
for example the access here doesn't
really look really nice so I can again
try to customize it through these
property inspector panel and also try to
change the label format uh as well right
so that's how you can create uh um
visualization designs like this U
dynamically in data illustrator just in
just a few
minutes um so reflecting upon this
research work uh I think um one of the
lessons we learned is that in we should
really try to argument and respect
users's current practices and tools and
in order to to to to do this we need to
come up with a set of primitive
abstractions which are composable and
also
interpretable um so after data
illustrator we continued this uh
research and then we were looking at
more complex data visualizations so for
example here we're looking at a fairly
complex layout used in the visualization
so this is a tree bar chart uh it's
showing the Import and Export revenues
um by different countries uh so we have
all these different bars groups of bars
uh corresponding to imports and exports
and they are arranged by different years
and then each rectangle here represents
a country colorcoded by their continent
um so when we show this to the um
potential users of data illustrator they
were they had no idea what components or
operations they should actually use to
create something like this and this
problem is not unique to data
illustrator right for any kind of a
visualization library or Tool uh it's
very hard to actually translate the
design you want into a set of operations
or Primitives afforded by that tool so
in fact based on our interview study
with visualization designers we found
that actually they rely extensively on
examples for both design adiation also
implementation but however they're
facing challenges in using examples
often times they don't really know how
to modify the example to suit their own
data set and needs and oftentimes they
face difficulties in trying to oper
operationalize the desired changes using
specific
tools so to address this problem we
looked into previous literature and we
were actually inspired by this idea of
reusing an existing chart uh so there
has been some work that tries to
actually convert for example the three
charts into reusable style templates and
also researchers from Microsoft research
also looked at how we can actually reuse
info Graphics charts however these Works
have their own limitations because they
mostly focus on style not layout and
they only support basic chart types uh
furthermore some tools also assumes the
examples are created by a specific Tool
uh which is not very generalizable so we
are interested in trying to understand
how we can support uh tool agnostic
reuse of complex layout in SVG charts so
SVG is a universal vector graphics
format that many tools are actually
using um so uh what if we can actually
just uh get an SVG chart um without
using its source code and without
getting its underlying data can we
actually try to reuse the design and
apply it to our own data set so at this
this year actually and the conference is
next week uh we're going to present uh
our work on this problem it's called
mysti deconstructing SVG charts for
layout reuse so here we we are adopting
a human machine collaboration approach
uh trying to solve this problem uh so
first we try to pre-process an SVG
example by detecting The Legend and also
the axis in the chart and since this is
not always uh 100% accurate we let users
verify the AIS and Legend EXP instuction
results um and correct any mistakes if
they have to and after that we try to
automatically deconstruct the main chart
content into a set of layout components
based on mascot the manipulable semantic
component Frameworks uh and then users
so here basically we came up with a
bottom up hierarchical clustering
algorithm trying to group individual
visual marks into meaningful groups and
also
layouts and then finally users can then
try to import their own data and specify
the mappings between uh these components
and also their own
data so here here is a demo of how
Mystique works so we have imported this
treap bar chart and uh um first Mystique
tries to automatically extract the x
axis and the y axis and the legend and
you can see there are some mistakes
right so Mystique Mystique misses the
year labels uh which is the second level
of xaxis and also it got the type of the
Y AIS R it should be numbers instead of
categories so we offer this interface
for users to actually correct all these
different mistake mistakes you can just
drag and drop these labels and then
change the uh uh data variable type and
then here we are going into the main
interface we're looking at the main
chart content and then here Mystic
actually tries to analyze and decompose
the components of the charts and then
got the user throughout a like a very
structured process so here first mysti
tries to highlight the first group of
rectangles and ask the user what this
highlighted group of rectangles should
represent in their new data set so the
user have a new data set which is about
uh uh Superstore uh sales so we have ERS
different order IDs category of products
subcategory region and sales speaker so
the user basically can just choose from
a drop down menu a saying this group
should be mapped to furniture and then
um bque basically goes to the next step
and are highlighting different parts of
the visualization and asking users what
uh data variable in a new data set
should be maed to that particular
component so it goes through all these
different groupings and then also down
to the level of individual marks and
then it goes to the uh and then it
proceeds to the encodings right so you
ask the user what the height of each
group should should represent and what
the color should represent the users can
just simply choose from a drop- down
menu and then all the visualizations
will update dynamically in real time um
so with this very simple wizard kind of
interface users can reuse an existing
very complex data visualization on their
own data
set right so uh in doing so basically
what MTI does is that it tries to
actually try transform the visualization
creation and authoring task and also the
skill requirement when users are using
Mystique they no longer need to
understand all the Primitives all the
components in a very complex
visualization framework instead all they
need to do is just trying to specify
which part of the visualization should
be mapped to which part of the uh data
data
set so uh I'd like to conclude my talk
with some quotes from uh Ed Edwin
hutchins's book cognition in the wild
where he's basically studying and
talking about the nature of cognitive
tools data visualization for sure is a
category of cognitive tools and hin
basically argues that tools permit us to
transform difficult tasks into ones that
can be done by simple pattern matching
by the manipulation of simple systems or
by mental simulation of simple systems
and tools provide constraints on the
organization of action by constraining
the representation of states that can be
produced to ones that are syntactically
correct it provides the use with
guidance as resources used in the
regulation of behavior so in applying
this argument in the context of M
basically we're trying to transform the
this difficult task of visualization
authoring into simple actions of
choosing things from a drop down menu
right and also we're providing
constraints by actually providing this
guided wizer interface U so that users
have less chance to make mistakes
mistakes and they actually have their
having structured guidance throughout
the
process so with that I'd like to uh
conclude my talk and uh thank you for
your
attention thank you
Leo um we have about 15 minutes for
questions um if you have a question you
can either type it on chat or feel free
to unmute yourself and ask the question
directly
okay while we waiting why don't I maybe
start with a question so you know this
this diagram that you're showing here um
for interacting with the visual system
like of course like you know you need to
have like goals and intentions and like
ways to input those intentions and then
you need to be able to sort of perceive
like you know what the system produce
and the generated output and like this
is sort of modeled after like the the
Hutchin Jim Hall and
like Alp of execution evaluation kind of
thing a lot of your talk sort of touches
on like either simplifying the
production of visualizations or like
abstracting out some of the algorithms
and techniques like what you showed in
the The Click sequence thing where you
know different techniques and different
algorithms produce very different kinds
of
visualizations so either for like a
designer or the end user of these kinds
of interactive visualization system like
how important is it for them to
understand the underlying algorithm or
technique and like you know how is the
visualization Community thinking about
like making this happen so they can have
more accurate mental
models right I think uh I talked about
two actually very different uh use cases
and potentially two very different kind
of user groups so the the work on event
sequence are mostly targeted towards
data analysts who need to do kind of a
more in-depth uh data uh exploration
work yeah and there I think it is
important for them to be able to
interpret what the machine produces to
them um so in that case oftentimes
showing an overview is often not
sufficient uh they that's why I think in
our as you can see in our first design
iteration we actually used uh kind of
like a overview first and then you can
actually do details on demand and drill
down into the individual data cases yeah
I think that's very important um in
order to for for you to really
understand how the what what these
summaries are capturing and how these
summaries are related to the uh raw
sequences for example okay and in the
second case it's more about basically
creating visualizations or authoring
visualizations and I think there um
because the end result or the end goal
is just to create something that the
user potentially wants and they sort of
know what they want at least that's in
the problem prop definition
right so we assume they have some
designs in mind or they have some
examples they want to reuse so in those
cases I think it's less important for
them to understand the inner working
mechanisms of the systems okay long that
they can be sure the system is on the r
track to produce what they want probably
that's good enough okay okay thank
you other
questions
yeah while we wait maybe I'm going to um
ask you about like you know how you're
thinking about all this work sort of
Shifting or like being augmented with
generative Ai and large language models
like obviously like recently even in
like the data visualization Community we
seeing more and more of um the use of
large language models that either like
abstract out the kind of direct
manipulation interfaces that you're
talking about both for analytics as well
as like you know generating these uh
kind of visualizations so I'm curious to
hear your thoughts about like where do
you think it can help and like what are
some of the limitations you're seeing
yeah definitely that's a very
interesting question and I think that's
on everybody's mind uh so I think uh I'm
thinking of two potential applications
right one is the in the generation or
creation of visualizations and the other
one is in the in terms of understanding
uh visualizations so in terms of
visualization generation I
think uh large language models basically
still tries to actually produce code for
you right so you describe what you want
potentially what data you have and it
tries to uh generate some uh example
code um for you and then you have to
basically run the code and then produce
the final visualization um I think there
are also LM can also potentially give
you design ideas as well so you can
actually ask questions such as okay I
have this data set how do I visualize it
and I believe it will produce some
reasonably kind of accurate
recommendations on the chart types you
can actually use so I think uh in this
sense it's actually very helpful for to
people who don't have too much
visualization knowledge or design
expertise uh just I think it can be a
good brainstorming tool for them to
actually identify potential
visualization ideas um I think in many
cases probably the code produced by LMS
are is going to be uh okay and you can
just use it and it works out of the box
but once something goes wrong I think uh
it still requires the users to have the
expertise to understand the uh kind of
the abstractions used in whatever
Library um the code is written in and
also requires the you requires users to
be able to actually change the code if
whenever whenever necessary so I think
there's still to incorporate the direct
manipulation uh in this process even
natural language interfaces as well so
instead of producing code and asking
people to change the code what if people
can just simply uh re like refine their
uh intent or try to point out mistakes
in the code and then the system can
actually try to regenerate the
visualization I think there are
potential research opportunities there
um and then in terms of hard
understanding actually I just tried uh
GPT 4V a few days ago and I was really
impressed okay I just give it like a
random chart like parallel coordinates
or whatever and and then ask it to
describe the image it does a really good
job of doing that uh uh based on my
experience it seems to be doing less
well in actually accurately estimating
the like the visual properties like the
positional size which I think is less
accurate but in trying to understand the
encoding like uh the design of the chart
I think he's doing a pretty good job
even with your tree map bar chart oh I
haven't tried that that's a good
question yeah I I didn't try that one I
should okay okay um thank you um if
there are other questions um feel free
to just unmute and ask or um type the
question on
chat okay well uh if there are no other
questions Let's uh thank Leo again for
the wonderful talk and uh I will meet
with you in a couple of hours Leo thank
you thank you
everyone